[Music]
hello you're watching the press preview
it's our first look at what is on the
front pages and it's time to see what's
making the headlines tonight with
politics editor of galden magazine moya
lothian maclean and the director of
communications at the institute of
economic affairs annabelle denham
they'll both be with us from now until
just before midnight a very good evening
to you we'll chat in a moment after
we've had a look at those front pages
for you let's start with the telegraph
leading with the latest warning from
president biden to russia that if they
use chemical weapons in ukraine nato
will respond in kind
actually also the same lead story on the
front of the guardian
kissing goodbye is the front of the
metro as the daughter of the russian
foreign minister is sanctioned over her
luxury london mansion and her bank
accounts and assets are frozen
the mail says the kremlin has labelled
boris johnson its number one enemy after
he claimed that ukraine could actually
win the war
sliding in the ft leading with the
admission to mps by the boss of piano
ferries that last week's mass sackings
of crew members were illegal but he'd do
it again to save the company
same lead story for the mirror with the
damning headline shame on you
here's your express it has what it calls
three stories of despair people
struggling to cope with the cost of
living crisis after yesterday's spring
statement by the chancellor
while the star has the downside of the
coming heat wave a warning that it may
be too dangerous for vulnerable people
to go outside because of the pollution
risk
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch and listen to us
and i'm joined tonight by politics
editor of galden magazine lawyer loving
mclean and director of communications at
the institute of economic affairs
annabelle denham great to see you both
thanks for your time this evening let's
start then shall we with uh the latest
on the ukraine situation and moyer the
front of the daily telegraph
quoting president biden we will respond
in kind if putin uses chemicals very
clever
use of wording there was a lot of
ambiguity we don't quite know what the
red lines are
but it's still a bold statement
well yes i mean bison was responding to
a question put directly to him which
said would you use chemical weapons if
putin used them so the only thing he
could really do to avoid escalation is
to use that vague language i think
frankly um he was at an emergency summit
in brussels of nato and g7 members where
they were discussing the current
response to events in ukraine what's
really interesting about this is
what we've seen and i think also your
correspondent uh touched upon this just
before the break is that the war in
ukraine is not going the way russia
thought it had um they thought it'd be
very very quickly instead we've seen a
concerted and determined response from
ukraine and in fact now people are
starting to say hang on a minute maybe
maybe russia won't win this at all
and and the questions are rising as to
russia in a desperate position what will
they do next
uh yeah i mean annabelle it certainly um
did show didn't it today uh just how
unified western leaders are nato really
never more united than it was today and
putin in fact getting the very opposite
of what he was intending
well yes of course just weeks ago he was
hoping and quite
succeeding really in stoking division
between
nato members if you can remember back uh
that far there was disagreement over the
sorts of sanctions that they would be
willing to impose particularly germany
reluctant to
cease north stream too which is now
subsequently done it's increased defense
spending so you're absolutely right that
there's a lot more unity among nato
members um
my concern is how vladimir putin is
going to respond to all of this i
thought before he sent tanks into
ukraine that he was a rational political
actor my worry now is that he's going to
think well
better to be hung for a sheep than for a
lamb you know is this sort of tough uh
if ambiguous rhetoric
really going to stop him particularly as
maya says when he appears to be on the
back foot the past four weeks have put
paid to the idea that ukraine would uh
swiftly capitulate or keeve would uh
even welcome uh russian soldiers russian
tanks this war is quite clearly not
going as putin planned um it's still not
clear how far
the west is willing to go the western
alliance is willing to go in this but
they've i think already gone further
than i was expecting
let's stay with ukraine but but a
different angle front page of the metro
kiss it
bye
jet setter daughter of an oligarch has
her assets frozen um tell us a bit about
this moya
so yeah this is uh the glamorous paulina
colova
she is the daughter of svetlana
pollakova who happens to be the
unofficial wife of sergey lavrov who is
a very high-ranking minister defence
minister in putin's administration and
she is now one of the latest
people with the connections to russia to
have her assets frozen so she is also
prohibited from traveling to or from the
uk and much has been made of polina i
think because her life is very
documented on instagram she's young
she's glamorous she's somebody that
people can sort of seize onto as an
example of what happens when these
sanctions are applied in real time um
but what is quite interesting is she
represents the international russian
elite the people who
well of the west is hoping will put
pressure upon putin um the more these
sanctions are applied to them there was
an interesting report in the times
yesterday suggesting if the war and
sanctions drag on uh top fsb officials
are already starting to
murmur just murmur about turning on
putin because they're very angry at the
way what that so they're called like the
new nobility they're very angry at the
sanctions that have been applied to them
and these sudden uh constraints put upon
their very elite lives they've been
leading all over the world so it appears
in that sense sanctions are sowing
discontent among the top tier of russian
society yeah also interesting that we've
not seen anything of the defence
minister and chief of the general staff
for quite a while now lots of questions
about
what they are up to what's happened
to them um let's move uh on from ukraine
then take a look at the front of the
guardian annabelle the fallout
from yesterday and they say sunak faces
a storm over failure to aid the poorest
well this is just
quite extraordinary really and i don't
think expected from the chancellor when
he sat down at the dispatch box
yesterday i expect that he thought the
speech had gone down and the statement
had gone down a little better than it
has at least 24 hours later of course
which you've seen that because has
really cultivated this very slick social
media persona his approval ratings have
uh surpassed those of his
neighbor he's been quite a popular
politician and little wonder because
he's uh spent an inordinate amount of
money hundreds of billions of pounds
protecting
lives and livelihoods um but now the
time has come for him to make difficult
choices and as paul johnson of the uh
institute for fiscal studies pointed out
today
he's really proven to be something of a
fiscal illusionist he's leading us to
believe um that he's no longer the
augustinian chancellor oh lord let me be
a tax cutter just not yet he was trying
to impress upon us that he is a low tax
tory and that the raising of the knicks
threshold yesterday and the pledge to uh
lower income tax by 1p in 2024 was
indicative of that um but actually i
mean in a sense yes of course as i
mentioned he did cut taxes
but he's also allowed taxes to rise he
can now expect to raise more in taxes a
share of national income by 2025 than he
expected last october the tax burden is
a 70-year high um
today he's been out on the media
explaining that there's a limit to how
much politicians can magic away we're
facing a costly living crisis inflation
is in the high signal single digits or
at least is expected to be um and of
course we've got soaring energy prices
which is partly um
because a global phenomenon although i
think that the bank of england montreal
policy committee has a lot of questions
to answer on that front and i think that
rishi soon acts right ultimately that
there is a limit to how much government
is able to protect people from rising
prices but nonetheless i don't think
he's been able to pull the wool over
eyes okay this time
all right yeah let's get a quick uh
quick thought on this from moya before i
asked moyer about uh piano i mean he has
been dealt the worst hand of any chance
in decades but has he has he missed a
trick yesterday
well i mean we're seeing the biggest
fall in living standards since records
began so i think that would suggest he's
missed a trick uh you know financial
experts say that his plans will push a
further 1.3 million people into poverty
i think the thing to remember here is we
throw around these numbers we throw in
these terms we talk about this but in
real tangible impact people are getting
poorer wages are having less real world
impact energy bills are going up
every every cost is going up possible
while the amount we have to deal with is
getting less and people are going to
suffer
today didn't he inaudible said he was
sorry but he also said that he did break
the law and he'd do it again
well he said he was sorry and he said
but he said it was what he needed to do
and i think what is interesting about
the piano um scandal is that it really
shines a spotlight on the environment
created for workers over the last decade
so the law that allowed uh peter
hepathwaite to fire 800 members of staff
and rehire agency staff who are now
being paid five pounds fifty an hour
because it's legal in international
waters was actually brought in by chris
grayling in 2018 which allows people to
sac create an exemption where mass
redundancies on ships regis registered
overseas could take place and the
government wouldn't have to be notified
um so you you're seeing the sort of like
the shortcuts that have created an
environment where workers are penalized
in order to create what people thought
called a modern company i don't think a
company that can fire 800 workers on
mass um especially in the middle of a
cost of living crisis is a modern
company or a company that we really want
to represent industry in this country
okay annabelle um just 30 seconds left
let's get your thoughts front of the
yorkshire post concerns for safety after
piano sackings i mean he says that piano
would have would have uh would have been
sunk sorry for for for no no pun
intended but you know he said this was
his only option to keep the company
going
well certainly it's true that piano has
been struggling it's lost a hundred
million pounds in each of the past two
years um i probably do believe help with
weight when he says you know ultimately
the alternative to sacking these people
was not that they were going to be on
the same contracts earning the same
amount it was that piano would
potentially go under so you know
obviously it was in a very difficult
position but that does not excuse the
way that it has treated employees it's
handled the process with spectacular
crassness um and i think there's going
to be an enormous fallout my concern is
that we're moving towards a battle
between piano and the unions with the
government trying to be seen to be
taking a tough line i think we just need
to remember those 800 workers who've
been affected in all this yeah we really
do really tough
for them of course we've heard from them
today
thank you both moya and annabelle